do you like scary stories let's see if  the new ghosts not the right stuff  Rachel we're all afraid of something  what are you afraid of submitted for the  approval of the midnight society I call  this story the carnival of dip a  carnival is coming to town this weekend  this is the same carnival for my story  that smile will haunt my dreams forever  [Music]  you have a dream about a creepy carnival  and now the carnival is real well you  don't have much time do you have a plan  let's do this seriously you can throw  time you sure about that I don't know  where was you  I'm going to end this look if the story  is too scary I can always tone it down  for you  [Music]  [Music]